à l'origine de cette épidémie de vache
folle certaines lacunes semble-t-il des
services vétérinaires anglais mais aussi
une pratique celle qui a consisté à
nourrir les vaches avec de la farine
confectionnés à partir de carcasses de
moutons morts d'une maladie similaire
explications eve mais tu es si les
vaches n'avez jamais mangé de viande
elle n'aurait jamais attrapé la maladie
de la vache folle le geste en cause
avoir donné à ses traditionnelles
d'herbivores un aliment contre nature
des et vo traduction des farines viande
hausse dans ses aliments
on met des rebuts d'abattoirs mais aussi
des animaux d'équarrissage ceux trouvés
morts dans les prés par exemple
parmi ces carcasses certains moutons
atteints de la maladie de la tremblante
le germe ainsi franchi la barrière de
l'espèce 1980 les fabricants d'aliments
britannique met sur le marché de
nouvelles farine de viande non chauffés
1987 six ans plus tard on découvre la
maladie six ans le temps d'incubation
les anglais suivi de peu par les
français interdits alors ces farines
animales pour les vaches et les moutons
on donne désormais ces aliments
seulement aux ports et aux poulets à
l'abri en principe de la maladie ainsi
depuis 88 ans grande bretagne et 89 en
france ou qu'un bovin n'est plus nourris
aux farines animales et ne peut donc
être contaminés mais tous ceux qui en
ont consommé avant 89 révèle la maladie
quelques années plus tard ceci explique
que les bêtes de boucherie jeunes soit
hors de danger
les seuls cas qui sont déclarés
actuellement le son sur des animaux qui
sont âgés de plus de 8 ans et qui ont pu
consommer ces farines de viande avant
leur interdiction
la banque 89 nous avons 89 on arrive
donc en bout de cycle
il n'y aura bientôt plus de vache folle
puisqu'il n'y aura plus de vaches assez
vieille pour avoir mangé de la viande en
france dans le